your setup is really simple but it works
like when you're like i don't wear
makeup and you're talking and you've got
your and you can see that you're on your
laptop
it's something it's it's it's like it's
that simplicity that's so hard for
people to
achieve but you guys did it so
brilliantly and i think that's why
you've been able to be so successful
during this time you know because you
guys really kind of like
you stop you didn't try to make your
show at home you just weren't like we're
at home let's make a show
no that's the thing i think that they've
done a really good job even when i was
in montana it was like well what the
hell how do we
make that work you know i'm like down
the middle of nowhere and i think we
just
i have a i have a crew like i've been
super blessed like
they're very like everyone can adapt i
think everyone's from like a different
part of the industry we've had to adapt
um whatever that is and i don't know i
feel like whenever any time you ever
you know you try like everybody was like
oh are you gonna do the whole thing
without hair makeup i'm like
well yeah cause i don't do hair makeup
so yeah
so yeah this is what's happening like
and i don't i don't want to not be
real like in a time when obviously i
can't have people over at my house right
now and
and um you know i you know want to be me
in it if i'm if
everybody's going to be doing this so i
don't know i'm just really lucky too
because my whole career i've had people
being like you have to do this you have
to be this you have to fit into this and
every i've had to fight every day
to just be myself and with this crew i
don't and with the voice crew i don't i
just i'm me and it's awesome it's fun
i definitely know that feeling i mean
yeah
it's constantly the association i'm okay
with this i'm sorry you aren't
you know also like i think a lot of
times people are thinking
they're like they think that these are
these are the steps to success
and they're like we all just want to you
know get get there together
and a lot of you know people don't
realize that like
the one thing that you have that no one
else has is you
and you exactly you're you're the ones
that you're the unique thing and i think
everybody
you know we're all told especially women
in this industry not to get all
feminists on it
but with women like being told like this
is what happens and this is how you
achieve
success and this is the blueprint for it
and i'm like there's no blueprint
everyone's blueprint is fresh
it's you it's whatever your paths are
like whatever
but i think people are so afraid i'm
kind of super thankful i come from
nothing
because i've already had nothing so i
don't fear it and i would did fine like
i was happy like you know so i think a
lot of people
fear losing and i just don't fear losing
i just like playing the game
i like playing you know what i'm saying
even like sports like i just i i enjoy
and when i don't enjoy it peace out like
right
the thing that for me the things that i
value the most
are my family my friends my
family and friends respect um my
intelligence my history my like you know
everything my my education and
those are all things that no one can
take away exactly
that's what i mean like if that's the
most important thing it's like then
nothing else is really that scary no and
i think it's not a lot of people come
with that level of confidence or
boldness though because they weren't
for whatever reason whatever's happened
you know somebody at one point
like i've met several people i'm like oh
man somebody told you you weren't good
enough and you believed them
like you know and that's the you believe
the wrong people and it's like
i've had plenty of people tell me i'm
not good enough at a
magnitude of things like multiple things
like but i don't believe them like i
think that's the difference is
really you know listening to yourself
rather than but it's also like people
are so worried about seeing
being so successful and and it's like
you know what is that it's relative
like you know so it's i don't know but
i do have um a strong sense of self and
i have
um me too i know like what my values are
however when you you hear
a lot about what success is what beauty
is
what talent is all this stuff over and
over there are those times where it kind
of clicks up in your head
and and and that confidence is question
so
it is it is really important that there
are more people like
yourself that you know i've been you
know throughout the years i'd hear like
you know randomly there'd be might be a
quote that you said
that was about body positivity or how
you felt about yourself or
the music that you wanted to do i'm not
a musician i'm not a singer
but like knowing that you were like i'm
gonna do my kind of music and
maybe there's some comment that you
you'd made in some interview
and that's in my brain somewhere so it's
like when you hear
you know other people doing it and
having that that same point of view
it starts to help build up your own
building blocks so whenever you kind of
take those little hits
that are inevitable yeah you kind of
you're able to kind of like
look around and go okay wait there are
actually people who are
who are doing it my way as well yeah and
just like what you said when people
start saying that stuff or
near me i've had a lot of artists that
are near me that we just have different
you know visions of what life is in this
industry and like what you're supposed
to do or whatever and it's fine because
there's room for everybody um in every
kind of opinion
but it's also one of those things where
it's like i know you're miserable
like i know you're exhausted from
keeping all that up and
and sometimes it's you know some people
are a certain way and that's how they
want to be but sometimes
a lot of times i feel like they're not
that way and they just feel like they
have to be
and it's like what possible success is
worth that because we're all
exp we all have expiration dates you
know what i'm saying we're not going to
last forever
yeah you're right none of us are
replaceable yeah it's like so
i don't know i don't know but i think i
feel like we have so much in common
though in that sense
me too but more than just one person
it's
the world that we're in so the
microaggressions that that are out there
in the world when you
when you are watching a movie and you
see a husband and a wife
and um they're talking about some
neutral topic
and the husband is um paying bills or on
his computer doing business and the wife
is putting dishes away
or cooking yeah it goes into your brain
in some small way that
that's what men do and this is what
women do so later on when you grow up
and you go
how can i do it all i don't feel like i
can do it all you if you feel guilty all
the time you feel like i can't be a good
mom i can't be a good
businesswoman i can't be a good friend i
can't be a good wife mother i mean
there's all these things
but a lot of times men don't stress
about that
because and it's unfair to them as well
though because they're little boys
watching all these movies like that's
what they're supposed to be doing you
know it's those little things that you
don't think that matter
really do yeah it works on both sides
you know
when you if if you raise boys
to believe in even the smallest tiniest
way
that women are worth worth less than
them
that will train them to treat women that
way
and i don't believe that that's what
humanly that we want to do you know we
want to
i i do believe that we all want
equality with everything no village will
survive that it will crumble
100 like you know and i think there's so
many it's it's really important for us
especially as women especially as a
minority woman to
do everything we can to open doors
and then also hold them open for the
next generation to come through
yeah it's not enough for us to just get
through the door we got to hold that
door open
100 i know you still do martial arts but
i saw these videos
and i don't know like let's see let's
like oh my gosh look at your kick look
at that what
yeah you should be a superhero like
another again you should do some
stupider stuff
that's um my fight coordinator fight
trainer from
um x-men i know i was going to say i
said again i was like we've already done
that
now that's i this is when i learned to
fight with this did you just wait
before what in that video it looks like
you do this whole thing and then you
wink at the camera you're like yes
you know because it probably took me
like 20 times to get it i kept messing
up and finally i got it at the end and
probably was like
okay you're so cool you might be the
coolest person i know with this oh my
kelly that means so much coming from you
you're the coolest person i know i want
to be able to do that
and then look up just so effortlessly
with my wink like
i'll teach i'll teach you i'll teach you
that that's really easy
i actually think i have that sword here
hold on i think i have that sword oh you
know
they let you keep something like that or
did you take it
i do i do i mean okay here's the real
question
olivia did they let you keep that or did
you just take it
well um well
here disney bought fox i don't think
they're going to come look for my swords
it was there's a merger it was that
nobody knew so i just took it um
that's so cool wait so wait
so will you show me something so this
isn't
going to hit anything okay i love that
you're in a dress dude this is um
i have to take my rings off so it's just
all on your wrist is that what's
happening
um yeah so i'm flicking with my wrist
like this and you open up with your
hands so it's like like this
yes so then you want to go like this and
then you're gonna
i would i would have cut myself by now
yeah
and you're in like this beautiful hippie
sundress just looking
like badass i can't stand you this is
i can teach you this this is a really
fun thing to you are literally my spirit
animal
like i want you i can't wait can you
show me anything simple
like right now simple i don't know
it's hard not to have anybody anybody
here to like show you or to do it on
okay i don't know i don't think i could
because well then that just
you're gonna have to come into the
studio and do it oh my god i i will
teach you
in the studio like a couple moves that
would be able to take
any grown man down for real i really
want to know yeah
it's really smart and it's hard for your
kids to learn how to do those things too
you know
absolutely like i said i'm not kidding i
want to i want to get them into some
kind of martial arts like what would you
suggest if they were going to go in if
they've never done anything and they're
young
well i did tkd which is taekwondo or
jujitsu taekwondo is really great
because it's um
it's a lot of form and it can be boring
at first because you have to learn all
these forms but i think that's so good
for kids like
i think about this all the time like
going to church as a kid you go to
church as a kid growing up in texas
i regardless if you wanted to or not by
the way
i know and so nowadays when i'm sitting
there like if you're at
somewhere like some presentation or
something or even a me
when you just don't want to sit there
yeah i have that muscle memory like i
can do this i can just sit here
you know i'm miserable and just kind of
like because it gets so boring sometimes
in like churches you just
you know if you're a kid too you're
sitting there so restless so i think
like
you know taekwondo it's there's a lot
the better you get the more active it
gets but in the beginning it's really
good for your kids to learn how to just
be disciplined
and do things that are really simple
over and over and over again
um but then jiu jitsu is really great
because jiu-jitsu
it it basically used somebody's body
against them their own body weight and
their strength so
so like if you can you can have a little
girl take down a big guy um by just
understanding how the body
moves and stuff oh my gosh i can't they
i've already brought it up to both of
them and they were both excited because
they see any kind of
you know x-men superman like the hero
thing and they're
my son literally just walks around my
house he's like four and he's just like
oh cool and he just like does this all
over the place he does turns and
and then he'll break into ballet i don't
know it's weird it's awesome that's so
cool
yeah he's very he's very multifaceted
well i am so impressed by that i
seriously at some point you're gonna
have to come when we can see humans and
have interaction and
moves okay yeah i will for sure
you